i have something for you today
which you might say is almost sad in a
way
this might be the saddest most pathetic
most embarrassing interview that fox
news host david asman
has ever done and i've been watching
david asman
on and off for decades at this point the
interview i'm going to play for you has
the feel and the vibe
of the north korean state media
broadcasts from how biased and
sycophantic it is
to the dear leader which in david
asman's case
is donald trump fox decided to interview
georgia republican secretary of state
brad raffensberger
who is a vile voter-suppressing
pro-trump republican
who has become an enemy of trump because
he has said listen i
i can't just steal the election for you
and that was even too far
for brian kemp and brad raffensberger so
david asman
brings on brad raffensberger and frames
up a question for him that seems like a
north korean state media question
framing up a question about how it
really doesn't seem like biden even
could have won
because biden was in the basement and
operation warp speed was so great
this is a reporter from the supposed
news side of fox news listen to the
frame up on this question
folks outside of georgia and outside of
other the highly contested states
saying look at these numbers joe biden
got
12 million more votes than barack obama
on barack obama's best election i mean
how is that possible he spent the whole
the whole campaign bunkered down in his
basement uh
not saying much at all uh the president
has had enormous successes with the
economy with operation warp speed etc
how could he have done 12 million more
votes
than barack obama that's that's really
the overall
writing question in most people's minds
again the people who are out of the
weeds unlike yourself you can understand
those questions right
i do just imagine that
asmin claims you know most people people
who aren't in the weeds most people are
thinking
i don't know i mean biden was in the
basement trump won with operation warp
speed and he won with the economy and
biden gets 12 million more votes than
obama must be fraud
that's the average person that asman is
pretending exists now
those people do exist there's no doubt
but it's about half of trump voters it's
not most people in the united states
here is brad raffensberger to his credit
saying that um this is the truth joe
biden got more votes and some people
can't handle it biden did win
and people can't handle the truth
sometimes because they're very
disappointed
in the results i don't get that i voted
for president trump also but at the end
of the day
we did everything that we could we did
an audit of the race president trump
still lost
then we did a full recount president
trump still lost then we
audited the absentee ballot signatures
of the envelopes
and cobb county and we found only two
votes out of fifteen thousand that we
went ahead and surveyed along with gbi
only two out of
fifteen thousand that weren't done
correctly and they were actually the
spouses that
filled out those applications for their
spouses or signed the signatures
and so we have a safe secure process and
people have to realize
that you need to get out and vote and
that's how you win elections getting out
and voting
is how you win which brings up a real
question about whether telling georgia
republicans
that the elections there are rigged is a
good way to get out the vote and by the
way
notice that in his answer brad
raffensberger
does basically agree with the premises
of the question from david asman
but he says the numbers just weren't
there raffensburger says
you know yeah it doesn't really make
sense i mean biden was in his basement
trump did great with operation warp
speed i supported trump
uh but we just couldn't find the votes
not enough people
turned out uh so even in his answer
there
um still conceding a bunch of the
framing of the question by david asman
so
there you have it and this is we there's
i mentioned this earlier one-upmanship
battle
i expect that once trump finally leaves
office
we are going to see um oan
and newsmax by virtue of their wild
reporting
push or drag some aspects of fox news to
become even more
radicalized to maintain an audience
that's my expectation
we'll see if it comes true